[Applause]
[Music]
um
all right l hello el uh where'd you grow
up where are you from originally
well i'm originally from burbank um i
grew up in orange county
um i lived down south for a little bit
and then traveled back to california and
tell me about tell me about your family
you had both your parents
no my mother is deceased and
my dad is in texas did your mom raise
you
yeah yeah
and how old are you i'm 19.
how would you describe your childhood
um
i'm pretty quiet um
it's in the state of my try to stay to
myself
um
i do enjoy new things
um i can be kind of um
eccentric sometimes
but your childhood wasn't traumatic no
abuse stuff like that
i mean when i was younger my mom's
my mom's brother
i was molested when i was when i was
nine
i left my mom's home when i was 16.
thank you
um
that went on for how long about
up until i left actually oh really yeah
you finish high school yes yeah
you started working as a prostitute at
what age i started working as a
prostitute when i was 16
when i left my mom's house
i mean i had to figure out how i was
gonna
get basic necessities and
i still wanted to make sure i finished
school at least
so i was staying with a friend until her
parents found out that i was
like there like
felt some of my clothes and whatnot so i
had to leave from there
and you're working with a pimp or on
your own i have a pimp
it's made things
fit um in some in some ways a lot
more difficult in other ways it's
i guess helpful one could say what how
in what ways is it helpful
well i've been robbed before
i've been raped on the track before
sat in jail
so so the pimp comes and helps you when
those
those things happen well yeah yeah
when when i went to jail he bailed me
out so i wasn't in there that long
what's the downside of having attempt
when you you don't bring in what's
expected of you
what happens i've had multiple black
eyes
my jaw has been broken
bloody nose
broke a rib
for me the alternative of being beat up
and robbed
because you're renegade right
it's not
you're damned if you do and you're
damned if you don't basically
and if you wanted to get out is that
even an option
i would like to say it's an option it
should be an option
i can't say i necessarily feel like it's
an option right now
so
i guess my honest answer would probably
be no
thank you for being honest you're one of
the few
so what what is your how much do you
have to make before you can
show up i have to make six
yeah that doesn't even matter what what
the weather is like and
whether
do you feel like you were tricked into
that relationship like he seduced you as
a boyfriend and then
turned into something different
yeah just like
big dramatic change
now i didn't even see coming in the
least bit
what emotions does this lifestyle bring
up in you
anxiety depression anger
all the above and just
anguish and
loneliness and
this is an endless cycle of pain just
are drugs a part of your life they were
yeah
i'm glad to say i don't partake anymore
but
at one point yeah
and tell me about the the men who pick
you up do you
respect and like them or well
for the most part men typically see
just an object so
attendance it all out
so to speak yeah the drugs help with
that
and then you have those like selective
few who are
genuine and respectful
but those are far and few
you work uh the street you work figaro
yeah
i went for girl i worked western
i've worked in el monte
i've worked in vegas along the strip
are you saving money are you saving
money
i try to until someone finds it and
but you're you're giving all your money
each night to to your pit yeah
so that makes it difficult for you to
try and save things yeah
i try and like hide something so i can
like put into like a
small piggy bank or something and
someone ends up finding it or something
and
i'm right back to square one
what do you think most people don't
understand about what you do
a lot of people don't understand that
like although there are
so called services to help
help you manage everyday life those
services don't actually do much
they do the bare minimum and
even when you try and
stay on a straight path
there's always something or someone
that's going to try and deter you
and to make you feel like their options
of what you should be doing are a lot
better than what you're currently doing
and
at the moment it'll sound so
pretty um
pretty advertising until until it is
what do you mean like
at first when we were dating he never
put his hands on me
and then it was like um presented to me
in a sense of
this would be helping both of us
and after i agreed then if they're not
found out about
other other women that i knew nothing
about
and then
it's just been
an endless stream of just
listen and assume lies like
and the deception gets worse and worse
as it goes on
so much worse
it's like this person's telling you that
they love you and they care about you
[Music]
but
in some ways they show you that they do
but then
it makes it really difficult to believe
anything anyone says
i mean you're very young do you do you
see that maybe this
what you're doing for money is changing
the way you view men
because you're probably interacting with
a group of men that are
not the most stand-up guys in the world
that's the way to put it
yeah okay so i've
become a bit jaded in a way that's what
i mean yeah you'll end up having a very
negative view of men and relationships
after doing this for a while
yeah and my
my problems that i encountered during my
upbringing weren't
so pro-male either yeah those are
those are the beginning of your problems
so
yeah my outlook on men is not the uh
most positive to say the least yeah
as someone who's just heard a lot of
these stories from girls like yourself
what strikes me is that
it seems like everyone that you're
interacting with all the
the other girls on the street the pimps
the tricks
the even the cops i think are probably
wanting something
everybody's everybody wants something
everybody's up to no good everybody's
deceitful everybody's
kind of out for their own self-interest
and it's just a hard
environment to go out there and work
really hard and risk your life every
night
yeah that would really get to me
it's difficult but i mean
i look around at the alternatives and
my optimism is
non-existent basically what do you think
would help you
think big
my own home that
that i wouldn't have to like worry about
if my
if my stuff is gonna come up missing or
if i don't make this certain amount of
money then i'm not gonna be let in
because i have my own set of house keys
do you secretly hope for someone
like one of your customers to
save you and take you away from this
sometimes and then i think about
what that person would then expect
the strings would be attached right
expectations
right it seems like even the people who
say they have no expectations
end up having expectations and i mean
that known as a part of human nature we
all expect something
from from everyone but i mean
be surprised how many people
are so deceptive
it's unnecessary
did you have dreams of doing something
with your life when you were younger
yeah you're still young but what what
did you dream about
i wanted to be a pediatric surgeon
great you know you still do that
you were a good student yeah
yeah you seem very intelligent thank you
you think you're addicted to this
lifestyle or do you feel more trapped
i feel more trapped than anything else
it's like everywhere i turn
so if you're working figaro street
you're probably working the in the 60s
yeah and of the girls that work the 60s
they're pretty much all with pimps um
to my knowledge yeah i mean it's
possible it's that they're not but
i try not to interact too much right
because sometimes he rides around and
like he'll get
like he'll get really mad
yeah what like if he sees me
talking to other other
other women out there that are working
and
i don't know it's like he assumes that
i'm plotting some plotting something or
it's really paranoid
what's the most important lesson you've
learned
you've only been doing this a couple
years but what have you learned
i've learned that
everyone's word isn't bond everyone is
not going to say what they truly mean or
how they truly feel
what they're truly thinking
it's up to me to have to try and
decipher it and figure it out
because listening to people all could
end up in so
many more horrible situations
thinking that just because they're
female like me so
why would they want to cause me harm if
i've never done anything to them
wow
yeah that has to be the one thing i've
learned not to trust
the words of others only words i could
trust are my own
well thank you so much for talking with
me and being honest
that's rare i appreciate it
and i wish you the best of luck with
whatever you want to do thank you
thank you very much